hi there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba and I'm John Humphrey we
are going to watch from a brilliant
YouTube channel who should be on their
way to a million subscribers as soon as
humanly possible I thought the last time
I saw their channel like a month ago
they were at 250,000 subs as of today
they are four hundred ten thousand subs
killing the I hope they climbed to a
million I hope we see more other videos
on the trending pages they are a
wonderful YouTube channel martial Club
it chapter 2 parody if Pennywise knew
kung fu action comedy I'm excited to see
what they do with this this is a top
rewards here video request from the man
who introduced us in the first place
named David Gandy yeah let's go into
this martial clubs cool with us covering
it they sent us messages they got
excited that we cover them guys guys
your channel is so much more exceptional
than ours we're just happy that you're
ok with this cover here's the honor the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
top-tier martial artists right expecting
this is fear
[Music]
have like consistently really good light
[Laughter]
[Music]
no Jackie trend is simultaneously
slating for an audition is did you go
wipe your ass yeah seriously Underpants
I'm done for
oh there's the picture
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh now
what the hell
a TRX
[Music]
[Music]
it wasn't a tr
it's just by simply running away from
can you know
oh they was must've pissed off their
neighbors is how I get this like one
spotlight here dude
and maybe that's why they hey and it
feels like a nightmare don't stop
[Music]
yourselves of sweet
[Music]
[Music]
I really can't wait to move this damn
[Music]
they shouldn't bet
[Music]
I mean there was a time job there's time
spent at least one point where he like
wife does an ass right there had to have
been like right before I got back into
better to cuddle with Annabel job well
done indeed man I really love the
commitment to more than just making some
type of spoof sketch where it's like a
penny wise fighting doing kung-fu moves
which of course is P and it's awesome
it's great choreography but it's also
earned and more ways than one
you guys actually committed to making a
horror comedy sketch yeah I always had
its own little narrative to it yeah yeah
there's a story's it more of like a
short film sketch in a lot of ways like
it it fanfic yeah is funny in the
beginning the I was kind of surprised by
the poop jokes it's such a prominent
motif I was like I'm not used to this
risk yeah from them especially and it is
funny to think about how they are just
hardcore expert martial artists doing
these juvenile this whole thing spirals
out of a need for toilet paper this is a
part of their part of the characters
fear though because I've often talked
about how that is one of the biggest
fears I have personally I had that like
cold sweat moment this morning why in
the bathroom here I looked over I was
like is there no toilet paper and then
it was behind me on the ledge but you
know oh yeah I was like oh god what am I
gonna do okay you know I just have a
general fear of going poop in other
people's homes you know has very timed
it's intense for some reason it's funny
when you poop you know if especially
feared a small group gathering yeah yeah
go to poop and you're like trying to
rush it cuz it's like if you're at a
sermon on time people will think you're
peed instead of pooped and by the time
you like walk out and if you've been in
there way too long a great thinker
should ha thinking [ __ ] didn't go to the
bathroom probably smells terrible I'm in
my late 20s and it's still the response
letter because it's the one aspect of
life that we just can't all get
comfortable with you know it's the one
place we are all equal as humans looking
silly and doing something unfortunate
there's a girl on the group I noticed if
what if I'm like with if
I'm in the groove and one of our friends
is clearly taking [ __ ] I'm like John's
probably taking his [ __ ] I was the one
girl who's like stop it Craig knowledge
things like that polite company
my point with that is that it is
nerve-racking but he's in his own home I
guess I made the whole bit rewarding to
me it's just the one line place and so I
because do you have I I thought we were
out of toilet paper because I couldn't
find it such as in a section here in the
apartment that's so it's like really hot
you get to the highest point but then
when they got to the street I was really
surprised by the type of sharp
cinematography of a commitment to a
horror narrative of a guy having to
overcome his fears and then the make-up
effects were cool on I'm so sorry I'm
not recalling um I used used to have
that actor's name at the top he's in all
of them so when the main martial club
guys the guy played penny wise in this
oh yeah will flash her name was question
the make about him was cool and they
actually did a lot of really great
editing with transitions in between the
cuts to amplify the horror FEX actually
instead of just penny wise solely doing
kung fu he did do some fake out mischief
the supernatural wise like when
Huntington when it's like a balloon or
whatever I thought that that is really
clever to infuse that as well really
showing yeah this probably the version
of penny wise if he did do kung fu slice
with Nightmare on Elm Street if it was
like Freddie invading a person's dream
like one of the later nightmare home
sweets you know yeah yeah well and one
thing I really do love about watching
martial club videos especially is
because you have you know this is
obviously a very now parody right now it
is huge right now I love seeing the
amount of like Hong Kong style
filmmaking the creeps into these with
like the under cranked fight scenes
sometimes that creates the sped up
motion I was wondering here if the ADR
was intentional or just a clever way of
avoiding having people get upset at you
in the middle of the night maybe you're
mouthing the dialogue are saying it low
and then replacing it later but it's
cool because yeah like these are well
assembled and they have a lot of clever
tricks that are very modern but also
some stuff that makes it clear to me and
I'm sure even more so to you that you
guys have studied these older you know
films and stuff like that and these
different martial artists and stuff so
what I will say is it does make it more
clear to me more than you oh yeah
because you've seen just qualitatively
more of those films I would assume I
would say I have seen qualitatively more
of those films than you yes things can
audition for you guys can I also but in
a little more time because I gotta get
back to my could I do back room I know I
mean I just got strengthen my back a
little bit but I would love to do
martial arts again I want a gold medal
one switch speaking of David Gandy just
won first place in the Ernie Reyes Diddy
yeah Wow afternoon yeah Wow for you Dave
man now that ego and rage head of that
shy timid six-foot-five gentleman is
gonna unleash yeah cool middle spit it
out yeah he's gonna strangle you to
death with it it's funny if you know
yeah yeah cuz David he's a very
thoughtful and gentle soul so thoughtful
you speak with him in person he he says
every sentence in his head first before
he says it
yeah he's very calm and he's very not
calculated but you know you can tell
that he's thought and considered what
he's gonna say before he says but
seriously marshal club he's got a
stretch practice for a month and I could
pass on camera I don't know if I can
keep up in a real fight but I could be
passable on camera so just let me know
if I cannot audition to be in something
with you guys and let me know if you
just want to fight me yeah off camera if
he John is pure adrenaline for your
willpower yeah come on the first ten
hits are to his own face by himself
yes I'm not crazy I'm in control no it
could hurt me more than I got myself
that's my secret to winning every
fighter that I do the most damage on
myself and the people like Oh what is
this guy and then you know that usually
ends right there I wanted to really
quickly before wrap this up bring it
back to the beginning of this sketch the
poop thing mm-hmm I have a theory and I
could be really reaching haha what I
could really be reaching here hahaha
but that you just do that joke twice
yeah really one for safety so nice I
gotta say Stephen King sometimes in his
books that has weird poop Bart stuff the
first book I ever decided to read from
Stephen King
what's dreamcatcher I saw the trailer
for the teaser trailer and the theaters
in like this was cool oh maybe I could
have that experience where I read the
book first I read half of a book and
there's all these weird things about how
there's the alien inside their stomach
so they keep farting and using the
bathroom obnoxiously it's it's really
gross and juvenile and then they put it
in the movie - it just doesn't play well
this is the most I've wanted to check
that film out oh part of my mind like
maybe it's in tribute to some Stephen
King's this is the detail that every
what's the difference between the it
movies of the book leaves out is maybe
there's a lot of pooping and farting I
put probably especially with the kids
the losers clever wouldn't make sense
alright reject nation thanks for
watching if you guys haven't subscribed
to marshal coffee yeah let's help them
get to a million followers as soon as
possible make sure to subscribe and then
ASAP you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell you
can check us out on patreon where we do
weekly human a is TV show reaction
stream alongs you can sync up and watch
along with us and there are several
shows that have reaction highlights
included so you don't have to worry
about that and he does music video
coverage weekly David we usually do
shots at the end but yours is like kind
of in the middle like this part see
Evette
you